hello
i got you guys
[Music]
[Music]
hi guys
okay
hi there i'm great how y'all doing
sure
perfect thanks guys
so
probably
um
[Music]
exactly
thank you
here
[Music]
okay
the alberta
[Music]
yeah he's moving
i think it's it's it's like the cooling
fan maybe yeah
that's it's still coming but i think he
said it's the cooling fan
as long as he can still move it that's
good
so
um
all right
thank you
uh
sir
[Music]
get
i'll leave though
hey harris well even as these
whistleblowers speak out the attorney
general bill barr made it very clear
yesterday
that the department of justice has not
uncovered evidence
of widespread voter fraud enough to
alter the outcome
of the election now after quite a bit of
pushback from the trump campaign the
department of justice put out a
statement last
night noting that quote that a partner
will continue to receive
and vigorously pursue all specific and
credible allegations of fraud
as expeditiously as possible but in the
words of the attorney general and i
quote he says
today we have not seen fraud on a scale
that could have affected
a different outcome in the election
still the trump campaign is continuing
to fight today
especially in michigan where rudy
giuliani is set to testify
before the state's house oversight
committee
but remember michigan certified the
election results
last week and president-elect joe biden
won that state by about 154
000 votes and so far none of the
campaign's lawsuits in that
state have been successful as for these
whistleblowers two
subcontractors for the u.s postal
service have come forward saying that
they witnessed
some irregularities with male imbalance
here's the white house press secretary
talking about that just last night
so there's a good chance that she will
talk about that when she steps up to the
podium
any minute now but she is also going to
get a lot of questions about what bill
barr
said and about the justice department uh
investigating this possible bribery for
pardon scheme which was detailed in
court documents that were unsealed
just yesterday harrison
thanks guys
the hokey pokey
so
good afternoon everyone the united
states constitution
matters even during a pandemic while
democrat politicians seek to impose
draconian restrictions against
their citizens this past week the
supreme court of the united states had
their say
on new york state's capacity
restrictions which restricted the number
of attendees allowed in
places of worship but not other
government-deemed essential businesses
justice gorsuch in the ruling said this
as he rolled back
governor cuomo's restrictions on places
of worship
he said quote it is time past time
to make plain that while the pandemic
poses many grave challenges
there is no world in which the
constitution tolerates
color-coded executive edicts that reopen
liquor stores and bike shops
but shutter churches synagogues and moss
behind me you will see displayed images
of democrat hypocrisy
playing on loop these images depict
the following they show governor gavin
newsom
of california dining both maskless and
indoors
at the fancy french laundry restaurant
despite severe
lockdown restrictions against indoor
dining for the very people
he governs you'll see chicago mayor lori
lightfoot
celebrating in the non-socially distant
streets
of her city you will see speaker nancy
pelosi indoors at a hair salon in san
francisco when salons in california
were only open for outdoor services
and you will see cnn's chris cuomo
staging his emergence from quarantine in
a made for telegen
television moment coming out of the
basement and this was after
cuomo was spotted breaking his brother
governor cuomo's quarantine rules to go
for a bike ride
in the hamptons also notable is san
francisco mayor london breed who
followed governor newsome's lead in
dining at the french laundry with a
group of eight people
and finally los angeles county
supervisor sheila kuhl
dining outdoors at her favorite santa
monica restaurant after voting to ban
outdoor dining at 31 000 restaurants
throughout
l.a calling outdoor dining a most
dangerous situation
quite clearly these democrats do not
follow their own edicts
they act in a way that their own
citizens are barred
from acting governor cuomo's decision to
impose restrictions on the size of
religious gatherings was rebuked by the
highest
court in the land but what was cuomo's
response
instead of showing deference to the
constitution
he attacked the legitimacy of the court
governor cuomo said this
you have a different court and i think
that was the statement that the court
was making
we know who he appointed to the court we
know their ideology
well in fact the ideology of those on
the supreme court who made the decision
to support
the first amendment are in favor of
freedom the constitution that survives
even during a pandemic
this statement from governor cuomo
strikes at the heart of the issue
democrats seek control these images
behind me make clear
democrats mindset rules for thee but not
for me the president stands with you
your freedom your ability to decide how
to best protect your health
we all know how to protect ourselves
from cobin 19 wash your hands socially
distance wear a mask
but as one federal court put it there is
no pandemic exception
to the constitution and with that i'll
take questions
welcome back christians good to have you
back so much good to see you thank you
appreciate it
i want to ask you about comments that
the attorney general made to the
associated press he said
quote to date we have not seen fraud
on a scale that could have affected a
different outcome in the election
given that why hasn't president trump
conceded
uh so first he went on to say this it
was in an ap
interview where he made that initial
comment but in that same ap interview
um he went on to say that he thinks a
lot of people are confusing
the use of the federal criminal justice
system with allegations that should be
made in civil lawsuits
and he discerned the fact that he said
quote there's a growing tendency to use
the criminal justice system
as sort of a default fix-all and the
campaign's litigation is all civil
little
litigation which is apart from something
that the doj would be involved in follow
up with you on that of more than 40
cases that have
been brought by the president's legal
team the majority
have been denied or dismissed the
election results have been certified in
all of the battleground states but the
president still think he has a path to
win
uh the president has said that he
believes all legal votes should be
counted and all legal votes should
not be counted and in fact the campaign
um is pursuing that litigation i can't
get into the details of that litigation
here
but they still do have active cases in
nevada and wisconsin have you overturned
the results when they've already been
certified in these battleground states
again the president is just looking for
every legal vote to be counted and i
will leave it to the campaign uh to
pursue their end
does he have uh faith in attorney
general bill barr does he still have
confidence in billboard
um the president if he has any personnel
announcements who will be the first to
know it
uh we'll go for janet thank you two
questions has the president have spoken
to
uh attorney general wilbar since this
comment came out yesterday
i'm not aware if they've spoken i know
the attorney general was here yesterday
for a pre-planned meeting with the chief
of staff and they discussed an array of
issues but
i'm not aware if the president has
spoken to him directly the president
considered
any preemptive uh pardons to any of his
kids is he talking talking to um
attorney giuliani about this
i've heard no mention um of any pardons
um and any conversations i've had in the
white house other than
the pardon of lieutenant general michael
flynn
a three-star general who i've discussed
from this podium before
who had his life ruined he was a valiant
hero who served his country both on the
battlefield and then came to work in
government and
what happened to him uh was there was an
fbi note that said they wanted to get
lieutenant general michael flynn to lie
there then was a criminal leak
of his identity and a phone call he had
he was told no lawyers were needed
in the discussion the fbi was having
with him um fbi investigators and after
said they did not
think that lieutenant general michael
flynn was lying
but yet he was still pursued in an
unjust manner and
the government failed to provide the
original fbi 302s from that interview it
was an
egregious miscarriage of justice and
we're finally glad that justice
was served for a war hero lieutenant
general michael flynn
david the president planning to announce
his 2024 candidacy
in a formal event here at the white
house before january 20th or even on
january
i've not heard any discussions of that
i'm aware of the reporting
but the president's campaign is
currently pursuing active litigation um
and
that is the focus at least at the moment
you heard his comments last night i
think
it sounds like he's planning to run
again do you know if that's the fact i
haven't spoken to him about that again
on his campaign is pursuing litigation i
would
redirect you to the campaign yeah yes
mark meadows has been meeting with
commissioner on what is being discussed
and also did the white house get a heads
up that the uk was going to be approving
the pfizer vaccine
um i do i'm not aware of any heads up
that we were given
but what i will say about dr han is it
is par for the course for the chief of
staff to meet with him as we're trying
to save
american lives with the vaccine in
record time in fact two vaccines not
only a vaccine in record time
um you heard monster salawi say a
vaccine normally takes anywhere from
four years to
25 years he said that in an interview
last week and this was in
10 months it's remarkable progress but
we still want to make sure that it comes
as fast as expeditiously
but as safely as possible uh because we
know by
that each day that passes there are more
american lives at stake so
we want to make sure it comes out as
quickly as the data allows it to
and we will have 40 million doses by the
end of the year which is a
tremendous achievement not just to have
gotten a vaccine in this time
but to have produced 40 million in
advance it's uh having a businessman as
president it's the trump vaccine
yes justin thanks i had a couple policy
things but first i just want to go back
to what you said about personnel
right before the election in a rally the
president suggested that he might
fire dr falchi after uh after the vote
that happened and so i was wondering if
you could comment on
what dr falcio's status is if you have
any questions
yeah i've had i've heard no discussions
of that dr fauci is still hard at work
on the task force
and then there were two things that the
president mentioned um
as policy uh goals that would happen
before the election that we haven't seen
uh any sort of obvious progress on so i
wanted to check in on those the first is
the 200
medicare uh prescription drug card that
was supposed to happen before the
election
it seems to have sort of vanished so i
wanted to give an update let me follow
up with the chief of staff on that
i haven't heard any current discussions
about it but i will follow up with you
uh he had also promised an immigration
order an
executive order on immigration that
would protect dreamers again he promised
that before the election
um he put forth on many different
immigration packages on hb1 visas and
others to protect american workers
um i will circle back but um there were
many iterations of immigration eos prior
to the election are those
does that work progressing at this point
are you sort of throwing in the towel
i think right now the focus is making
sure that there is stimulus relief
for americans who are hurting right now
so that is the current
active policy priority that we are
working um on moment by moment along
with copen
yes yes kayleigh as demonstrated by the
large red ribbon outdoor in the white
house yesterday was world aids
day the president issued his
proclamation yesterday but consistent
with his previous three proclamations
uh omitted any reference to lgbtq people
even though they bear the brunt of hiv
aids
the president included a reference to
racial and ethnic minorities so why not
lgbtq people
the president um honored world aids day
yesterday in a way that no
president has before with the red ribbon
there
and i think that he commemorated the day
as he should have
there's no reference charlotte go ahead
i wanted to ask about uh section 230
is president trump willing to allow
government shutdown over there
and the national cancer vote uh the
president has made clear
um the importance of 230 um
and he i would point you to his tweet
about how that pertains to the nd
aaa um one thing i would say when you
look at 230 just to explain
for the american public exactly what
that is it's essentially
a shield that is given to social media
networks because they claim to be
uh the public square but in the case of
twitter twitter has become a publisher
choosing to fact check certain content
um and when you're a publisher there are
certain responsibilities
with that you should not be immune from
liability
and when you look at what twitter has
done on the ayatollah khomeini we were
just looking at his
twitter account before coming out here
and just a few weeks ago the ayatollah
khomeini of iran
tweeted quote why is it a crime to raise
doubts about the holocaust something
not worthy of a flag by twitter which is
despicable when you think about it also
the ayatollah has tweeted that israel is
a deadly cancerous growth
that should be uprooted and destroyed
something that twitter did not deem
worthy of flagging or blocking in its
entirety and in fact twitter executives
defended uh that move in front of the
knesset
this is a very important issue one that
there's even bipartisan agreement that
something needs to be done
uh so the president will be unashamed
and fighting against that kind of
vitriol that we see and very
hateful language that twitter is
publishing
kristin thank you just one more question
about section 230 the
democratic chairman of the house armed
services committee he
put out a statement essentially saying
that these two things are not
related section 230 and something is big
and important for a national security as
the nbaa so
i just want to be clear here is
president trump seriously considering
and talking about
vetoing the ndaa over section 230
yes the president is serious about it um
and i noted
um you know when you have other world
leaders that are making calls for
genocide and twitter not finding that
worthy
of flagging or blocking uh beyond that
um you look at
china who's putting out disinformation
china uh tweeted out
uh i believe it was six days ago i think
it was november 25th that kobit 19 did
not originate in wuhan
something that was not deemed worthy of
flagging by twitter
there are real grave concerns here and
the president stands by that
um and it also is worth noting that the
president will always defend our
military
ensure that we get adequate defense
funding as he's gotten 2.9 trillion
dollars
so far but he is going to put the
pressure on congress to step up on this
and one more question about attorney
general bill barr's comments i believe
you said that
president you're not sure if president
trump and the attorney general have
spoken
since he made those comments is that
right yes i'm not sure if it's spoken
but can you at least tell me when was
president trump upset when he heard the
attorney general say that
he has not seen uh or the doj has not
uncovered evidence of widespread voter
fraud enough to overturn the outcome of
the i haven't spoken with the president
specifically about a.g
bar or um that comment and i would also
uh just point everyone to
um to the revised or the supplemental i
should say not revised um
uh comment that was put out by a.g barr
in the wake of media reporting that
seemed to misconstrue his statement
um he said this that some media outlets
have been
not he i should say the doj spokesperson
some media outlets have incorrectly
reported
that the department has concluded its
investigation of election fraud
and announced an affirmative finding of
no fraud and that is not what the ap
reported nor what the ag
stated i think a lot of the media didn't
read beyond that one comment
the civil part versus the criminal part
i think maybe the discrepancy
is you know you have members of the
trump campaign coming forward and saying
that there
is hard evidence of widespread voter
fraud
enough to overturn the outcome of the
election and then you have the nation's
top law enforcement officer or the
attorney general
saying if there is he hasn't seen it
well the attorney general was speaking
to what has come before his desk um
and again i'd point you to the campaign
for specific um
questions on this but i would just say
generally they are pursuing pursuing
civil litigation which in fact the
attorney general explicitly said
some of this is meant more for civil
litigation which is what the campaign is
currently pursuing
kevin taylor is the president uh
seriously considering
skipping the inauguration um i'll leave
that to the president to make his
announcement he tweeted something to the
effect of he knows what his decision is
and he'll
make his decision at the right rationale
could he possibly have for skipping i'm
not going to speculate on the
president's decision i'll leave that to
him
to announce it there was a report
yesterday on federal officials
investigating
a potential bribe for pardon scheme
has anybody at the white house been
questioned
by federal law enforcement officials
regarding
potential bribes for funding no and in
fact the doj official said yesterday
that no government official was or is
currently a subject or target of the
investigation
uh disclosed in this filing yeah andrea
yeah
so thanks for uh my question i wanted to
ask about
uh fbi director ray though it looks like
president-elect biden wants to keep him
in the job does that
change the president's perspective on
fbi director ray and
is does he retain full confidence in him
yeah he's made no assessments and at
least in my presence about that and if
we have any personnel announcements
we'll let you know
okay can i just follow up on the um on
the vaccine issue you said 40 million
doses
recall the president saying and perhaps
even you
saying that you were looking for 100
million doses by the end of the year
that 40 million is quite a bit short so
can you just uh clarify that
number so there are currently six
vaccines
that we have identified as vaccines that
we were hopeful
would come to fruition and with each
with several of those if not each of
them i can follow up with you on the
exact number
um we have manufacturing contracts we
have manufactured doses
with several of these um but it is we
they have to come to completion
so with each new vaccine that comes
along with that will come
millions and millions of doses that have
already been manufactured in time
um but currently of the four vaccines
and phase three clinical trial madeira
pfizer astrazeneca
and jansen uh two of those have gotten
to the point of applying for an eua so
really
um it's incumbent on the uh the
manufacturer and those um
those going through the phase three
clinical trial uh to get that data to us
and then
it's manufactured and ready to go so the
moment someone else um
gets to a 94 effectiveness rate or
whatever the barometer is
um we will have those doses yes
yes georgia officials have said election
workers there are facing threats because
of the president's
false claims about winning the state and
his renter throughout the election
does the president condemn threats
against election workers or does he take
any responsibility for
those threats we condemn any threats
against anyone there's no place for
violence um what i will say though too
is that you know the president's lawyers
um they were doxed by
a left organization their private
information put out so we're seeing that
um happen to people on both sides of the
argument
and there's no place for that ever
anywhere real quick
uh the cdc director today said that the
next few months could be among the worst
uh public health months in american
history i wonder does the white house
is it setting a good example for the
public for the white house to be
in-person holiday parties
at a time when uh the cdc and other
organizations are asking americans to
forego those kinds of celebrations for
their own safety
yeah so you know if you can um loot
businesses burn down buildings engage in
protest
um you can also go to a christmas party
um you can celebrate the holiday of
christmas um and you can do it
responsibly
um which is why the east wing has noted
that they'll have smaller guest lists
masks are going to be available social
distancing is going to be
encouraged um hand sanitizing stations
among other measures
but we will engage in the celebration of
christmas um and
there will be a hanukkah celebration as
well yes um
yes meredith um thanks
does president trump um has he had any
kind of
conversations with allies on capitol
hill about challenging joe biden's
um electoral college vote with congress
we saw one of his allies today said he
plans to do that
is that a conversation with the
president at all not that i'm aware of
penis the white house coronavirus task
force is
privately telling governors uh that
americans under the age of 40 who
gathered
uh with people outside their household i
think thanksgiving are dangerous to
others and should isolate immediately
why is the white house not publicly
sharing that same information with
americans
you said that was in a what document was
that white house virus task force is
privately telling governors
that those that thanksgiving
celebrations that i've there's
there's cdc guidance out there as to
when you should and should
not isolate so i would point you to that
um that's all been publicly available
since the beginning of all of this
christian thanks haley so if some
version of the defense
authorization makes it to the
president's desk with language that
terminates
section 230 will he sign it into law
even if
there's language in there that renames
faces very confederate
you know names or named after
confederate officials yeah he's said
before um he's very much
against the warren amendment um and
public polling is with him
on that um how that intersects with the
230
tweet um i will have to follow up with
him about i don't know if that position
has changed
um given what he tweeted recently but i
will follow up on that and then on china
yes uh joe biden told the times that he
doesn't want to roll back the china
tariffs for the phase one trade deal
you know if the president plans on
reaching out to mr biden
to talk about you know china trade since
it's been such a hot policy issue
uh or any other policy really before
january 20th
i'm not aware of any plans of that at
the moment but if i if i do i'll let you
know
yeah here it is
some examples of um you know lawmakers
who've been talking about cova but i am
curious where is president trump been
in offering public leadership on this
topic of the coronavirus especially as
we've seen
cases surge we haven't seen the
president make any sort of public
comments
um or even tweets about this surge in
cases so i'm curious what sort of
examples you have
yeah uh quite a bit i mean he's created
the greatest testing system in the world
he gave
a press conference about two weeks ago i
believe on the vaccine
which he has done at warp speed because
he's torn down bureaucratic barriers
he's been
hard at work he's done i don't know how
many coronavirus task force briefings
from this podium
but the work he's done speaks for itself
the fact that now the case fatality rate
in this country
is two percent um it was six percent in
april and
um what that means is it's a testament
to our therapeutics another thing that
happened recently in fact
mid-november got almost no attention but
it's again a testament
um to the president is uh the two new
therapeutics they are renditions of mon
one is a monoclonal antibody another one
is a regeneron therapeutic
and these two therapeutics are given to
people with mild to moderate covet
symptoms that are at high risk for uh
severe covid or hospitalization
so the fact that we've got to the point
where we now have therapeutics we can
give you in advance to try to prevent
you
from going to a hospital and we've sent
out uh 169 000 vials of one and 36 000
vials of another
just in a few weeks he's hard at work at
this with the task force
behind the scenes and when we talk about
his public leadership
just on kova generally i think it's a
fitting time given your question to note
dr falchi now says that we should keep
the schools open he said that this
sunday
this is something the president has said
for months it caused me to go back
to july and look at one of my briefing
books from july 16th
2020 um and what i found in there was
this
the science was always on our side about
keeping
schools open way back in july it's being
acknowledged now but in july you had dr
redfield saying
unlike flu kids are not driving the
transmission cycle
you have dr atlas who has been a leading
voice on keeping the schools open
saying everyone else in the western
world our peer nations are doing it we
can do it
this was back in july we had a study
from the netherlands
about few reports of infections from
schools that had stayed open
this was back in july you had a yale
school of public health professor
named albert coe saying that the bottom
line is the impacts of coven 19 on
children is minimal or very low
compared to other groups there was a
lancet quote to that same effect this
was back in july when the president was
saying keep the schools open i'm looking
at the science
it's detrimental to keep kids out of
school but what were democrats saying
when the president was following the
science
here's what democrats were saying would
governor gavin newsom
say this i'm not taking pressure from
trump on opening schools
good governor cuomo saying it's not up
to the president about opening schools
as schools were shut down you had mayor
de blasio who interestingly reversed
himself
this week and now kids can go back to
school but back in july when the science
was on our side he was saying what we
won't do is ignore the science and
recklessly charge ahead like our
president who was
always following the science you had
jennifer rubin tweeting that now he
wants to kill your kids
i'm not sure how that's responsible
reporting and then you had anderson
cooper
saying that he actually just doesn't
care about kids at all
nor the health of their teachers and
parents and you had the american
federation of teachers and the national
education association
railing against the president as well
the president's followed the science
he's also kept in mind we have a
constitution and he will be unashamed
and always advocating for the science
and the best interests of the children
of this country thank you very much